this week we'll come and see you from
the past Chuck everything we experienced
through our senses has happened in the
past because we see things not as they
are but as they once were because of the
light travel time between us that's
awful
especially when you consider my past I
don't want to know your past all I know
is this is we love science
hey everybody welcome to wheel of
science the interactive show where we
answer your questions about the universe
I'm your host Chuck nice and I don't
answer your questions we have with us as
usual the one the only dr. Neil deGrasse
Tyson what's up Neil you know I love
doing that so Neil you're beaming in
from Vegas huh yeah I got it I got a gig
tonight I give it a public talk on
astrophysics there is some learning that
goes on in the town apparently I was
gonna say that's the most exciting thing
I've ever heard happening in Vegas well
one thing is for sure we know we always
win when we bet on the other grass Tyson
are you really betting on the universe
when you bet on me because all I am is a
conduit to it I meant bet on the black
anyway Oh Sonia what time is it my
friend let's just spin the wheel there
you go annalisa se Katrina Li says my
daughter's ages 8 and 11 want to know
would it actually be easier to travel
forward in time rather than backward and
what would that require oh we can easily
travel forward in time and we've known
how to do that since 1905 Einstein
special theory of relativity lays out
the whole recipe of how you can move
into the future and all you have to do
is go into sort of a lower gravity field
relative to other people or just travel
very fast and your clock will tick
slower than that of everybody else that
you've left behind then when you return
you'll be younger than your twin for
example if you had left your twin back
on earth so in that sense you are
traveling into the future that's easy to
do and we've known how to do that
travelling backwards that's the problem
and it takes we think we can do that I
have some colleagues who've made some
calculations that assert that depending
on a or a trajectory you take around a
black hole you can come out and end up
in the past of when you started so but
that takes extraordinary setup to make
happen but right now no problem
traveling into the future so it's either
lower gravity travel faster than the
speed of light or very good more
to riser and not only that the GPS
satellites which are farther away from
the center of the earth and we are they
experience less gravity than we do and
GPS clocks tick faster than our clocks
yet we're getting our time from them and
so they know this in advance rather
we've programmed in the relativity
correction to compensate for this fact
so that when they do give us the time
it's the right time not the relativistic
time that it wants to keep by being
where it is in orbit awesome
all right Neil you ready for the next
question spin the wheel how
theoretically might time travel be a
wormhole work whoa oh yeah
so what a wormhole enables is by the way
if you manage to travel someplace faster
than light you have the capacity to move
backwards in time
that's we've got that one established as
well we just don't have any easy way to
travel faster than light but one one way
that's been celebrated in science
fiction and you can write it out on
paper legitimately is a wormhole a
wormhole I'm over here and I want to get
over there and I want to get there
quickly I want to get there before the
end of the commercial break okay so you
could travel through a wormhole that
changes the effective distance between
where you are and where you're going and
then you sort of look around when you
get there and you find oh my gosh I've
traveled a hundred thousand light-years
in a matter of a moment okay when you do
that you have the capacity to move
backwards in time relative to when you
left now you don't get to visit yourself
you're in a sort of a different
space-time trajectory so you can't shake
hands with yourself before you left that
so if that's what you're thinking of
doing no and by the way there's a huge
there's a huge paradox that people worry
about and and many people including
Stephen Hawking the late Stephen Hawking
worried whether this paradox would
prevent
backwards time travel completely because
if you go back in time and prevent your
parents from meeting one another then
they wouldn't have ever given birth to
you to go back in time to prevent them
from meeting one another first of all
let me just say I stopped listening when
you said I can't shake hands with myself
alright we have to take a break now but
we'll be back with more of your
questions and a caption contest
featuring a picture of Neil doing
something weird
thanks to Wix for supporting this
episode of we love science have you been
on the fence about making a personal or
professional website
Wix is here to help you get it done
loads of templates for any need dozens
of fonts to match your vision which has
you covered to create your own
professional website go to wix.com slash
go slash Startalk make sure you use that
special Startalk link we also put it in
the description hey send us your sites
in the comments welcome back to we love
science it's time for another question
you're ready neo spin the wheel check
[Music]
Eric fire that wants to know this what
would you say is the most accurate
time-travel show or a movie and why hmm
it's really hard to do an accurate movie
and still have interesting plot lines so
given that they take some loosey-goosey
steps with it with time travel I have to
say that Doctor Who as a TV series is
the most invested in the authenticity of
their time travel storytelling and so
they thought about the contradictions
and the paradoxes and they have their
own solutions to all of that now on the
on stateside I would say there's nothing
like the original back to future movie
the first one that one they thought it
through they imagined consequences they
so I
give both of them sort of equal high
ranking and as a special mention
you gotta love bill and test Bill &
Ted's Excellent Adventure come on I mean
that's that such a special runner-up
special mention for time-travel exploits
all three very good the most disturbing
of the three definitely Back to the
Future where you have to make sure that
your parents smash so that you can be
born okay everybody it's time for a
cache of contest where we took a picture
of Neil and you provided the captions
and the winner is Harry sulk with
astrophysics they're great two thumbs up
on that one so my my caption was cuz
you're like this I want to saw a black
hole this big time now for our we love
science pull if you could time-travel
would you travel to the past or the
future make sure that you answer the
poll and leave comments on this video
hey everybody that's our show and as
usual it's a pleasure to have the one
the only Neil deGrasse Tyson with us
thanks Neil the truck I'm delighted to
always be in arm's reach of you no
matter where I am in the yeah and I know
that's how you like to keep me at arm's
reach don't think I forgot about that
restraining order
what website will you make with wins a
photography site a wedding site a
personal site wits will help you get
your site up in just minutes don't
believe me
I created the wheel of science comm on
Wix in the same amount of time as I
created all three of my children okay
that's almost correct you can see it for
yourself I was able to embed every
episode of the show on the site I add a
custom thumbnails for each episode so
they each look special I just had to
click on the text boxes in the templates
to put in titles and descriptions for
each episode there's no reason why you
can't start your site right now
even a comedian can do it go to wix.com
slash go slash star top and make a
professional website today you can
upgrade it and add your own domain and
get some great extra features with their
premium plans click on that link in the
description and get started on your
website right away hey everybody next
time I'm Chuck Knights and thanks for
watching wheel of sight
[Music]